[Музика]
привіт, мене звати Наталія, і настав час
для нашого уроку англійської мови, тому я сподіваюся, що
ви всі щасливі та здорові, тому що
ми знаємо, що нам для цього потрібно, нам потрібен
спорт та смачна їжа давайте поговоримо про
спорт  перш ніж ми розпочнемо наш урок, я хотів
би, щоб ми побачили, що ми робили на попередніх
уроках, звичайно, ми переглянули
різні назви спорту в
приміщенні, ігри на свіжому повітрі, командні види спорту, індивідуальні,
навіть екстремальні види спорту, і тепер ми знаємо,
як використовувати їх під час гри.
розповіли про найпопулярніший вид спорту
у світі, футбол зараз, я сподіваюся,
що ви можете пояснити, чому вам подобається чи не
подобається той чи інший вид спорту, і можете
трохи поговорити про свій спортивний
досвід, також у нас були деякі граматичні
модальні дієслова, які ми  знаємо, що таке прислівник і
прикметники і яка різниця
між цими двома словами,
і тепер ми знаємо, що я сподіваюся, що це як бути
хорошим, краще і найкраще, використовуючи
ступені порівняння, ми знаємо, хто
найшвидша людина в світі, але також ми
знаємо, що повільний  бігун може виграти
гонку, якщо буде продовжувати наполегливо працювати та
тренуватися, а також ми знаємо, як наші власні
назви, тому ми починаємо їх з
великої літери, і, звичайно, у вас
були домашні завдання, давайте перевіримо,
це було ваше домашнє завдання прямо на
електронну адресу  англомовний друг
про вашу думку, який вид спорту йому
вибрати. Добре, давайте подивимося на цей лист
і перевіримо, чи є в ньому всі необхідні
інгредієнти, як-от привітання, вступне
слово, хороші чи погані моменти з причинами,
ваша думка, заключні слова та ваше
ім'я, добре від Девіда до
теми мережі  скейтборд або баскетбол
давайте
почитаємо це привіт, це вітання так, ви
запитали мене про мою думку, який вид
спорту вибрати: скейтбординг чи
баскетбол,
це вступне зауваження гарна наступна частина
скейтбординг - це чудовий спосіб насолоджуватися
на природі, але це дорого,
є  багато спорядження, яке можна купити, як-от
шолом для скейтборду та спеціальний одяг,
і це дійсно небезпечно,
баскетбол дуже захоплюючий і не
такий дорогий  платити це навчає вас командним
навичкам, але це також може бути небезпечно, ви
можете легко отримати травму.
знаю, як це відбувається, це останнє
речення є заключними словами тато це
ім'я, тому ми маємо всі необхідні частини в цьому
електронному листі, тому я думаю, що це чудова робота,
наступним завданням було діапазон назв або
видів спорту, різних видів спорту від
найнебезпечніших до найбезпечніших, це  список, який
я склав, щоб ви могли порівняти та перевірити його
зі своїм, тому я думаю, що
катання на гірських велосипедах є найнебезпечнішим видом спорту, а
шахи - найбезпечнішим боксом,
небезпечнішим за теніс, тому ви можете порівняти
всі ці види спорту,
використовуючи які ступені порівняння чудові, добре,
і це  смішне кумедне завдання про створення
власного виду спорту для поєднання сноуборду
та каное, це може бути веслування на каное на снігу, чому
б ми не використовували Kanoa для вирощування повій -
спускайтеся на санчатах з п'яти добре, і тепер,
перш ніж ми знову почнемо наш урок
давайте зробимо швидкий тест, ви повинні вибрати
правильний варіант, і з трьох я
прочитаю речення, щоб ви дали трохи
часу, ви дасте своїм батькам, а потім ми
порівняємо з моїм другом, добре, давайте перейдемо до
речення, коли ви граєте в теніс, яким ви б'єте
м'яч  ця ракетка або палиця добре
дають вам кінець, і це ракетка, ви маєте
рацію, наступні хокеїсти повинні завжди
носити шолом, рукавичку або кепку, щоб захистити
голову ваш ремінь
добре, звичайно, це шолом наступний
, нудно спостерігати за їхніми почестями
в басейні  трек О, персик, твій батько добре
так, звичайно, це траса, тому
ця траса спортивних залів і проведена, і
останній тиждень він хотів покататися на віндсерфінгу,
плавати або кататися на лижах, але
снігу не було, твій варіант хороший, звичайно,
він пішов кататися на лижах добре  настав час
для нашої вправи, давайте трохи порухаємося ми
говоримо про спорт. Ви пам’ятаєте
правила, якщо я дам вам назву
виду спорту, ви б використовували в грі, ви повинні
плескати в долоні, якщо я дам вам
назву  види спорту, які ти будеш використовувати з go
you mime going and if I you
dos the sport which we use with ti нагинаєшся вліво,
нахиляєшся вправо, як бендер добре, так ти
готовий трохи порухатися, тож давайте припинимо
кататися на лижах
так, це кататися на лижах баскетбол грати в
баскетбол добре  йога потім ліва лава
справа добре аеробіка також штани ліворуч
підгоріли правий скейтборд так ми йдемо
кататися на скейтборді теніс грати добре шахи добре
це також гра пам'ятайте, що граючи в
шахи добре
бокс
не бокс - це ми займаємось боксом пам'ятайте
цю хорошу роботу,
тож давайте далі  Звичайно, спорт – це
те, що нам потрібно, щоб бути здоровими та щасливими, але
це може бути небезпечно,
тому що ми можемо отримати травму, добре, подивіться на
цей текст, я виділяю кілька слів, як-от
і але, тому що коли ми хочемо додати
щось, ми використовуємо і коли хочемо
виразити контраст  здорові щасливі, але
ми використовуємо небезпеки, але коли ми хочемо
пояснити, чому ви вже
знаєте це, ми використовуємо, тому що добре, тому як
бути безпечним у спорті, звичайно, нам потрібне певне
спорядження, і нам потрібно мати
навички, але що ще далі давайте
поговоримо про травми травми ви не
знаєте, що це означає, але я прочитаю
ваші речення, і він здогадається, що
означають ці слова номер один Джон
впав зі сходів і зламав ногу зламав
свою, що ви знаєте  це слово, тому що
break broke broken це звичайне
дієслово, яке означає знищити щось
добре, номер два, деякі книги впали на мене на
мене, і я поранив свою голову, я поранив голову,
як тут, коли ти щось поранив,
ой, це боляче, це боляче номер три він
послизнувся і вивив зап'ястя
розтягнув зап'ястя подивись на цього бідолашного
він вивив свого півня Рут Себастіо
вивив його зап'ястя і останній, що вона
впала і потрапила
на очі, ви можете побачити це на
картинці, ця фіолетова річ на її оці
у синцях, але отримати синці, щоб мати це на
її очах, добре, а тепер давайте подивимося,
як ви зрозуміли, як ви
запам'ятали всі ці значення, вам
потрібно викреслити старе слово
те, що не підходить до цього рядка  e
перший ви можете зламати собі живіт ногу
що це не підходить це так
живіт ви не можете зламати свій живіт
номер два ви можете вивихнути талію і
подзвонити або знає, що не йде на цю
лінію так
ні ви не можете пружинити свій ніс  і
останній
отримаєте, ви можете отримати синяк на задній частині зуба,
о, я, що не ходить в цю компанію, так,
ви не можете отримати синяк на вашому зубі
добре, давайте йти далі,
добре, і зараз ми попрацюємо з цими трьома
уривками, які вони  різні, і
наприкінці нашого уроку ми дізнаємося, що
таке листівка, що таке огляд спортивних подій,
а що таке лише оголошення.
Добре, давайте розглянемо перші чотири правила, щоб
уникнути травм,
давайте пройдемося по категоріях, які вам
потрібні, щоб зрозуміти цю травму проходу
травма повторити за мною
травма травма травма ця lova видалити
Атішу
і отримати травму травматично подорожувати
належним чином Нілеш на ім'я Джіно щоб
уникнути уникати одиниці неслухняний
розігріти резерв Реваті серозний
доповнення ігнорувати нас Осанна п  болі в
невротичній болі, біль підліток, лікар
наказує лікер і неважливо, що б не
значить, ви піднімаєтеся, тож
давайте пройдемо ці чотири правила,
щоб уникнути травм, бля, чию попою, сер
подорож номер один, ви повинні
правильно розігріти перед матчем  ви повинні це
схоже на дуже важливе правило номер два,
ви не повинні ігнорувати біль, воно говорить вам, що
щось не так, номер три, ви повинні
відпочивати між матчами, ви повинні робити це,
а потім я за, що ви повинні відвідувати лікаря команди
раз на місяць ні  неважливо, що добре,
ви бачите, що перше друге
та третє дуже суворі правила, ви повинні
це робити, пам'ятайте, ми використовуємо його, коли це
дуже важливо зробити, і ви повинні
ми подивимося, що це трохи пізніше, добре,
тепер давайте подивимося, як ви зрозуміли
ідея цього тексту, ви повинні вибрати
правильну версію добре,
тому гравці повинні тренуватися між
матчами серйозно сприймати біль або сказати
лікарю про будь-які травми, подумайте трохи
і дайте вам варіант
добре так
п  пласти повинні серйозно сприймати біль, чому
як ви думаєте, чому дайте мені свою
думку так, тому що там сказано, що
з вами щось не так, добре, ми використовуємо
стріляти або не повинні, коли ми даємо
комусь пораду або коли ми говоримо, що
щось добре чи погано для цього  людина, до якої ви
маєте звернутися до лікаря, якого хоче за
місяць, незалежно від того, що ви знімаєте, я даю
вам пораду, це дуже добре для вас,
ви знаєте, що робити, ви не повинні, але ви
повинні робити це добре, ми не використовуємо, ми
повинні використовувати, тому що  це більш м'яка
пропозиція, ми після зйомки чи не
повинні використовувати базову форму, ми повинні побачити, що слід відвідати,
слід відвідати добре, а тепер давайте
трохи потренуємося, виконаємо деякі вправи, це поради
щодо здорового способу життя.
і
використовувати стріляти або не слід, як
приклад, не лягайте спати занадто пізно добре, і
як порада, ви не повинні
лягати занадто пізно добре, давайте зробимо це
наступний раз, їжте більше фруктів і овочів
добре,
ваш варіант  наступним чином ви повинні їсти більше
фруктів і овочів  один
не їж багато солодощів твій Берендт
так, ти не повинен їсти багато солодощів,
це не корисно для ваших зубів, розслабляєшся
ти справді повинен
ходити до школи йоги і так, ти повинен
піти до школи, наступний раз лягати спати рано, і
ти повинен йти до  спати рано добре, а
останній багато займається спортом, звичайно, ви
повинні багато займатися спортом відмінно далі
тепер у нас є два стовпці, один - це проблеми,
а інший радить, як вирішити ці
проблеми, спочатку давайте порівняємо їх, а
потім складемо кілька речень
звичайно, спочатку давайте прочитаємо їх я
стаю товстішою це проблема я не
маю грошей добре це також проблема
моя спина болить
я відчуваю стрес у мене болить голова
я втратив квиток я думаю
уроки важкі й тривалі  один у мене
немає енергії, це буває, і деякі поради,
як вирішити ці проблеми, отримати роботу, робити
більше вправ, робити йогурт, щоб допомогти
вам розслабитися.
давайте знайдемо  давайте порівняємо перший
з порадою добре я товстію,
що буде їхня порада, як ви
думаєте, так робіть більше вправ номер два у
мене немає грошей, що ви порадите,
що буде ваша порада так
влаштуйтеся на роботу
номер три  у мене болить спина, яка буде
твоя порада в цьому питанні і не грати
сьогодні у футбол так, ти маєш рацію,
я відчуваю стрес, займайся йогою і займайся йогою, щоб
допомогти тобі розслабитися у
мене болить голова, випий води
я втратив квиток шукати  я
думаю, що уроки складні, якщо
ви говорите цю розмову зі своїм учителем,
а останній у мене немає
сил,
ви повинні так з'їсти щось, звичайно,
ми добре попрацювали, ми відповідали їх проблемі та
пораді, а тепер давайте скласти речення
з має і не повинно подобатися,
наприклад, номер п'ять, номер п'ять, що у нас
є у мене болить голова, ви повинні
випити води
або, наприклад, MA у мене немає
грошей,
ви повинні влаштуватися на роботу або, наприклад,
урок  Урок дуже складний,
що ти повинен робити ти  Поговоріть зі
своїм учителем, зрозумійте добре
наступний наступний уривок – спортивні новини, дозвольте мені
прочитати це для вас навіть без присутності
головного тренера пана.  Діккенс, наша шкільна команда
продовжує перемагати минулої ночі, вони перемогли, побачив
Саутпорт 45:23 смертельний, капітан
набрав 20 очок, але йому довелося відсидіти
останню чверть, тому що він вивив
ногу, дядьку, вибачте, тому вони
стали зарезервованими словами, які вам потрібно
розуміти присутність прасад туман
головний тренер головний тренер колонія тренер, щоб
виграти параму красуня
- бити - параметр курс ми йдемо до
курсу капітан Капітан і до розтягнутих
щиколоток список неслухняний Чикаго не може ризикувати,
але щиколотки добре, тепер давайте подивимося, як ви
розумієте, як ви зрозуміли
ідею  з цього тексту, як ви думаєте, що
баскетбольна команда зробила погано після
травми Теда лише одну або має дуже
хороший сезон добре так, дуже хороший
сезон
добре, це дуже короткий уривок з
лише дуже важливою інформацією, наприклад, тоді
ми зовсім нова школа
адреса читала Road Springfield тоді дуже
важлива в інформації, коли суббота,
14 червня, і деякі важливі примітки, які
батьки повинні відчути в листі дозволу
та повернутися  це до школи до
1 червня і деякі контакти зателефонуйте для отримання додаткової
інформації лист
дозволу це Dullsville поверніть
Prager nutty і заповніть поет ок так
як ви зрозуміли основну ідею цього
тексту, щоб дитина взяла участь у
спартакіаді батьки повинні  зателефонуйте до школи,
щоб повідомити, купіть їм нові тренажери
або віддайте підписану форму назад до школи,
подумайте трохи,
який ваш варіант так,
батьки повинні повернути підписану форму
в школу, а тепер давайте вирішимо,
яка листівка яка  огляд, а
який із них просто оголошення з дуже
важливою інформацією добре так, ви маєте
рацію, перше це листівка
з більш детальною інформацією про
правила, щоб уникнути травм номер два, це
огляд спортивної події про спортивну подію,
яка вже відбулася, і
оголошення  невелика коротка
інформація яка дуже яка
яка дуже важлива для майбутньої події
добре добре давайте підемо далі і
доповнюємо ці фрази новим що
w  накази, які ми вже вивчили добре,
має значення дозвіл на щиколотки та
зігрівання, перший рядок – це так, дозвіл
номер два, незалежно від того, який номер три
так, тренер номер чотири вивив щиколотку
або стигмати Сікоку номер п’ять розминка
Розаріта окрема Махіна мене так Даніель
останній заповніть формулу, щоб
заповнити добре, і це невеликий текст не
маленький, але дуже простий текст про
день спорту в Британії, ми можемо прочитати його самі,
тому що це дуже легко, і я хотів би, щоб
ви відповіли на певне питання, одне питання:
чому  У британських школах влітку є спортивні дні,
і чи є у вас спортивний день у
вашій школі, але я прочитаю це для вас,
це дуже легко, мене звати Емма, і я
з Великобританії, мій улюблений день у
навчальному році — спортивний день, спортивний день у
Британії  Багато веселих шкіл зазвичай
проводять спортивні дні в
деяких ближче до кінця навчального року,
тому що тепла погода і сонячна погода,
діти біжать на перегони і намагаються виграти
призи або
трофеї, часто пропускаються забіги  перегони в мішках, які
стрибають у відстій, або триногі
діти біжать парами, прив'язавши ліву
ногу одного бігуна до правої
ноги іншого бігуна,
батьки дітей приходять дивитися спартакіади
іноді бувають перегони для мам і
смертельні випадки, що є у всіх  чудовий
час, добре, до побачення, Емма, і останній,
який я хочу, щоб ти пам’ятав про використання
форми інфінітиву та форми ing, пам’ятай,
що після слів, як-от love hate enjoy
and go, ми використовуємо дієслово з ing для закінчення,
наприклад, я люблю грати, давайте
плавати
номер два  Ви повинні пам'ятати після
слів хочу хотів би чи хотів би ми
використовуємо до нескінченності, і ми використовуємо це для вираження
мети, наприклад, він іде плавати,
щоб підтягнутися, це вираз мети,
так що неважливо плавати в них, вони можуть сказати
Platinum shabu, щоб підтягнутися до чіабатти
запах для мене я хотів би спробувати
кататися на сноуборді після would like we use для
утворення infinity і після модальних дієслів can
mass якщо ми використовуємо голий інфінітив
без до example you should visit your
d  октор, якщо ти пам'ятаєш це, давайте
вправимось це добре,
заповніть деформацію дієсловами в перервах
добре я прочитаю вас я прочитаю це для вас
дати вам трохи часу, ви даєте своєму другові,
а потім ми порівняємо з моїми батьками добре
мені дуже подобається ok  приготування їжі так, ти я
ненавиджу це я не можу навіть яйце,
я навіть не можу зварити і це тому, що після
роботи моделі ми використовуємо перед ведмідь-ведмідь
формальний інфінітив номер два я б хотів
трохи вправи добре я хотів би зробити трохи
Доступ хороший я теж
давайте бігати разом сьогодні вдень
давайте разом бігати сьогодні вдень
добре, і наприкінці нашого уроку, як
традиція, у нас є цей дивний вид спорту
, ви коли-небудь бачили екстремальне прасування, але
воно існує, ви бачите цього чоловіка, який рухається
на човні з  прасувати одночасно
на цій залізній книжковій дошці добре, і ваше
домашнє завдання, будь ласка, виконайте ці
речення про вас я люблю почніть
щось робити, щось робити я хотів би
щось зробити, а потім створіть
свій власний вид спорту з цією гімнастикою і
що це  зима добре це я  На завершення
нашого уроку дякую до побачення і будьте
здорові та щасливі
[Музика].